okay we'll get started this is the
subcommittee on the um Family Court
committee on uh G's and parenting
coordinators
um so with respect to
G's
uh I had a couple of questions
uh U that I needed answered I was going
to email judge Ashley which I hadn't
yet
um one of one of the questions is on
specification
of uh the um charge of the G are are
they
specific um are they gray
areed um I understand there's no uh
recommendation uh but are they specic
are the judges specific as to what
they're looking for uh this G to deliver
in a
report and and the other one was uh with
respect to mental health or substance
use yes they are they are charged to
have a
specific specific
issue so so and with respect to
um mental health and
substitutes are there clinicians used
for determining I know the I know the
court that I
visited um there there one of the
parties was supposed to get evaluated on
their own uh that didn't happen uh the
judge gave another three months for this
person to get
evaluated uh which I found problematic
uh because he had three months and he
didn't do it right uh there was another
three months given and
um the party was getting visitations and
the other party was concerned uh with
his alcohol use um and it was
you know that he was given another three
months to see the child uh you know I
would have thought that it was okay the
visitation over until you come back in
three months and we have a uh uh uh
substit
evaluation uh so so it it appears that
there's
not that it's up to the party that in
this case the judge left it up to the
party for that party to get uh
themselves
evaluated uh which I'm not sure if any
of them would use a
um a clinician and and say you know set
up an appointment with this person uh
and when you come back we're expecting a
uh you know a report um
evaluation um so yeah if you
get
good morning representative just for
record purposes Erin krian general
counsel for the courts uh thank you for
these questions um one of the things I
have to say is that I am the general
counsel so I am not as expert in each of
the subject matters as some of our
judges like J Ashley name again I'm
sorry Aaron krian Aaron okay um but I I
will be happy to get you these questions
and others that you have and and have
the judges write them for you but as a
general matter people do find their own
clinicians there could be different
considerations cost local locality for
them you know if the court were very
restrictive and who they could use that
it could be an expensive person or
someone who's far um so there there is a
little flexibility there but I think
that the courts are very receptive to
your inquiry into whether there is a way
to provide more mental health expertise
to the courts unfortunately a lot of
these things are at people's own
cost um and that's just the money that
we have is is not available for those
services so it's it's certainly
something worth looking
into
okay so so when a judge orders a a um
alcohol
evaluation um that's on the person to
pay for that evaluation typically yes
okay um and it's I mean it the person
that it's uttered on doesn't have the
option of saying I don't have any money
so I don't know how I'm going to get
that done they can they can submit
Financial affidavits but they're not a
lot of funds that are dedicated you
think of something like for example the
J fund has the guardian and liem fund
has not been funded um I'm not sure when
it was last funded but it hasn't been
funded for a number of years so there
would have to be a specific fund that
the court could draw from to to cover a
particular cost that the person could
then submit a financial affidavit and
show that they're eligible based on
criteria that the legislature sets but
there is no there is no funding for any
of that I'll I'll check if there is any
circumstance whether in a particular
case it would be covered out of an
existing fund okay but I know that there
are not there's not a
dedicated fund for
that okay any other questions anybody
may
have I just noticed um after going oh
I'm I'm Judy um Linda um and um
basically um I noticed that when I did
go to court um with listening in that it
seemed like a lot of people had problems
finding a spot to go to uh where they
could go to get the mental health or or
their evaluations um and that is where I
think it it definitely if they're going
to be um that they need need to go to
these there has to be some places that
are going to accept these um because
that's the only way to move forward in
order to um get them the proper
evaluations that they need because
otherwise otherwise I mean how are they
going to get the assistance that they're
going to
need
go do you know if I'm sorry
representative Greg do you know if the
G's they're always they attorneys from
what I'm seeing it's attorneys I don't
know if they're always attorneys I would
have to check on that I think that's
frequently the case Okay um
representative Kataba has actually put
in a bill that I'm interested in that
we're going to be looking at um this
year but it it really talks about rather
than only having an attorney doing it
especially whenever we have these
nuances of that go beyond the legal
realm when they're more in the mental
health realm but actually where is so um
somebody that would hold a bachelor's
Master's or doctorate degree in
Psychology law Social Work counseling or
be a family practitioner so that there's
a wider range of what we're we're
looking for
um I mean I guess is that something that
we will just discuss this bill when it
comes up I assume this would come up
before us so um I
certainly that's the direction I've
always been headed in since we first
heard about the gal here that I'm I'm
concerned
about basically so somebody that might
need more legal help is not somebody
that can afford a gal anyway because
they might be more prosay so um I guess
do I even have a question
um do you even do you know how often the
gals are used currently I think they're
frequently requested but they're they're
frequently not able to be afforded by
the party so there there's many cases in
which they're discussed as an option but
it's just not possible for them to
afford to have one appointed yeah we
heard two cases representative Lon and I
actually went to the courts together and
we heard two cases where they requested
it but were unable to afford it so so do
do we have data and how many are
requested and uh due to uh
financing um they're not provided I it'
be helpful to know what the Court's
needs are uh that are being met uh with
respect to G's uh whether the judge
would want the G to help determine
something and because of finances it's
it's not available so I don't think we
have a system whereby a person is
necessarily putting it in a case
tracking system where I could go and
pull a report but what I could see is
the last time that the fund was funded
how much the draw was when the the
guardian lium fund was funded that might
give you a pretty good idea of what the
interest
is go Ahad can we file anything with
like that would have a budget type thing
or does that have to wait till next year
because I I'm really interested in
trying to get this funded for indigen
families again yeah it would uh it would
be difficult in the off year to get
funding as we went through the budget so
so be something we'd have to look at
next session yeah okay yeah
and uh I think I already asked this but
I'm not sure if I got an answer the the
um are there times where the judges will
specify you need to go uh you need a
mental health
evaluation um and you need to go to
Manchester greater Manchester mental
health uh for that evaluation or
or or will the judge just say uh you
know I'd like to have you get a mental
health
evaluation and you're on your own
I think it's it is I will check that for
you I think it is typically not
specified exactly where to go okay but I
will check that for you and make sure
that that's accurate
okay uh and I think that would be
helpful uh last time that we did have a
fund for G's um how quickly that fund uh
would uh decrease I I remember years ago
when they had that fund that was always
that issue
um you know we're down to 1,500 or
1,800 um so that'll take us three or
four more and we have another six months
to go or what have you uh so that that
would be
interesting
um yeah and also also with respect to
the parenting coordinator do the judges
feel that that would
reduce have the potential of reducing
conflict have the potential of uh
parties coming to
conclusions um I I I'd be anxious to
know if if uh you know they sense this
this would happen um I one of the things
I think is is tough for the judges in
answering the question is they know the
New Hampshire system very well and
sometimes they're not necessarily as
familiar with what may have been
successful in another state um there are
certainly a smaller number of high
conflict cases that take up a lot of the
Court's time because they have to uh for
everyone to have their opportunity to be
heard I think it's hard for the
practitioners the judges to know this
will be the thing that changes that
because they don't have direct
experience whereas someone working in
another state might say yes this has
been very successful or it has not been
as successful as hoped when we
implemented this system um it's
certainly something that they're
interested in and I think it's good they
they they definitely are interested in
solving some of these issues and giving
more services to people in high conflict
cases but it's tough to project whether
this would be the thing that would help
reduce that conflict versus neutral case
evaluations versus the mediator with a
different background um I think that's
not something that they have necessarily
studied um but certainly want to give
more services in high conflict cases so
is it fair to say that it um it would
Aid it would relieve the judges of
some issues having somebody to help them
uh because if there's no parent parental
coordinator the judge is doing that uh
or or trying to affect that to to bring
less you know conflict um so the fact
that they have somebody that could help
them with that um on its face looks you
know whether or not we know it's going
to accomplish the goals that we're
looking for it accomplishes yet to be
seen um but that you know that the uh
cases that I heard um it was
overwhelming uh I felt for a judge to
have to deal with a lot of a lot of
proads that he's dealing with and and
you know that they're not
um you know they're not in any rush it
appeared to me in my opinion was that
they weren't in any rush to fixing
anything they were comfortable in the
conflict um and the judge was looking in
my case the judge was looking to uh to
reduce that um so having
another another person helping in that
uh on its face would seem long
it is certainly worth exploring and and
I don't think that the judges would say
no to more resources for for cases that
um do take up a lot of court time and
which are important to resolve correctly
okay okay so just in looking at the case
text for what the idea or the updated
case text which is section um G
5302 it looks like New Hampshire code um
you know it talks about the what the
guardian at Liam is I probably initially
assigned to do but one of the things is
to come to an independent conclusion
about what's in the best interest of the
recipient but we now have legislation
where they cannot make a recommendation
is that
so I'm almost looking at if the
current the current ramifications we
have or restrictions we have I'm just
wondering how effective this actually is
because they
can so it says that they formulate a
recommendation which they can't do now
or such other report as directed by the
appointing court so really they're an
investigator for the court that's all
they are and it's just they're just
looking into things kind of Pi kind of
thing for the court is that what I'm
understanding they certainly have an
investigative role um which is they're
they're seen as an extension of the
Court the time that the court not able
to necessarily give to look into all of
these matters independently so I I think
that's a fair
characterization
okay I mean I would say with the current
restrictions on a gal funding that are
saying
that I guess I just don't see it being
as successful right now I see more
Hang-Ups with it because of their
limitations and um their backgrounds and
stuff I don't know I
actually even if
somebody say they can't afford it but we
assign it to them besides just being an
investigative tool I'm not sure the the
benefit uh the way that it currently
sits
right I mean I don't know about you
but what would be interested also is uh
of the G's
appointed uh how many of them are are
one party's paying or they splitting
that that would be interested to know
too um to see how many are uh onesided I
you know to know how many are dropped
because nobody has the finances uh how
many one side pays and how many both
sides split I may have to obtain an
anecdotal estimate on that for you but
I'll I'll see what I yeah that would be
fine that would be fine and um
and what I'm understanding is it's it's
specific you know when there's a g
appointed it's to look for a specific
issue that the judge needs to know
typically it's an assignment from the
judge to the guardian at lium to look
into a delineated issue or issues and
report back to the court okay so so it's
not a wide as wide as uh
uh you know you're charged
with reporting to me the best interest
of the child I have wide open seen one
that broad it is it is typically more
targeted but I will check that there's
not a scenario in which you would have
for example like a catch all at the end
or You' say I want you to look into all
these items and let me know if you
encounter anything else that relates to
best interest okay and is there a time
is there a time frame that they're given
um so let's say that the next hearing is
in two months um the is the G expected
to report within that time frame for the
next hearing do you
know I think it might vary Case by case
because some of the investigations may
be very easy and simple and some may
take longer for one reason or another so
it it may vary between case whether it's
a shorter assignment or a larger one
okay and at the hearing each party can
object or question uh the report of the
G absolutely are they are they told that
uh do you know did the judges tell them
that or or do they have to automatically
know so if the G gives a report that's
not very good to one party uh could that
party uh interject or not interject but
say I disagree with XYZ and for whatever
reason why uh and are they told that if
they don't agree with the gao's report
can we um you know feel you know
you're you're um you're okay with
letting us know why and the reason why
uh you don't believe it's correct I
think they get it in writing they get a
sort of just a so they get a copy a copy
of the report and and sort of general
information but let me see if I can look
at the writing and see exactly what's
written in it yeah with with the High um
Pro uh uses I think the more that
they're told um you know the the more
it's less apt to uh be confusing or or
leave after hearing saying I didn't
agree with what the G said and you know
I don't know if I had an opportunity to
dispute it um I just wanted to be clear
that they they know um they could
dispute it
and it I mean this data is probably not
kept uh
but
uh the determination of the
G
um what percentage would lean towards
the person
paying uh I know in children and family
law for years we hear about you know the
G lean to
towards uh my ex because they were
paying um you know so I'm wondering if
if there's some way to know uh you know
was fair to both parties or it leaned
towards one party and that party
happened to be the
payer
um because my understanding is there's a
set limit a set amount of price however
it could be extended
so if I'm a
G and I'm looking for the
income um I know I got
$600 uh however I could get another $600
if uh because the person that's paying
me can afford it um if I leave something
in my report that the judge could extend
me for another $600 or whatever whatever
the costs are you know um I I I don't
know how often the extensions are I
guess would be you know how often are
there extensions uh for another report
from the
G I know that that is that is not a
perception that the judges have it is it
is not necessarily measured but
typically because they're giving sort of
their factual findings there's not as
much room if the findings aren't robust
then they're not persuasive to the judge
so even if you were trying to to wait it
it would it would be difficult to do um
so I know that that's that's not the
judge's perception right now that they
see a bias from from guardians edl item
but I will certainly see if there's data
I I don't think so because it's it's
just not sort of tracked in that way um
it's it's in our different Case Files
but not necessarily in a way we could
pull out to run a report um but I know
that that is not the judge's perception
okay any other questions
or
so I think that's that's all I um I got
a lot of a lot of homework there that's
all right I'm gonna go uh thank you for
giving them to me because uh there's a
few different people I want to check
with to make sure I get everything so it
is helpful for me to have all your
questions so I can check with all the
different offices in the Court Circuit
administrators different judges and make
sure I get you a full picture so I
appreciate you giving me the questions
to take back I'm starting to I'm
starting to lean towards we were better
off when we had a when we had the
funding that made it fair for for
everybody uh and it helped the judge uh
you know and you know the cases that I
heard uh with prays I well there was
four cases eight litigants and uh one
attorney for all you know in one of the
cases and
and I'm like what did you know the judge
has no court help uh like when I was
going through divorces back in the 80s
um you know uh
so I I see the strain on the judge
um you know so so it was especially when
you get a
conflict
um it's more difficult to peel young to
get to the bottom of the facts uh so
yeah that that those answers would be
very helpful and then yeah you know do
do we really got to think about putting
putting a line item uh for um G's back
in and I believe it was Judge Ashley
that said that the average was 120 to
130 an
hour I believe I remember that that was
a similar number okay
okay okay and if they were
attorneys I'm thinking that
at the lower end
of I mean if I hire an attorney on a
deal it's probably 200 250 350 300 right
so uh so the 130 I'm wondering if that's
is that enough to get enough
interest
um that that is a good question because
we are in a a nationwide labor shortage
so it is it is harder to get people for
things that we could have gotten them
for in the past they're in demand in
other places uh so that it I think
that's our our average cost now but
that's a good question if we expanded it
would we be able to attract enough
people at that price and um we may not
know the answer but I can certainly see
if we have any information one way or
the other that we do know people that we
think would be interested or many of
those people have moved on they're not
available anymore I'll see if we know
that are there any G's that volunteer
their services or or is it all uh under
payment there there's no pro bono G's
I'm not certain if there there is um I
know someone in the audience is
correctly mentioning that that Casa does
make themselves available on a volunteer
basis use and neglect cases only yeah
for many things there may be um
attorneys that do it as proon I'm not
certain of that but typically pro bono
for an attorney would be um you know
maybe a week or two a year so it it may
not be we just may not have a bar that's
large enough and interested in this
particular right subject um and also you
do typically want folks that are well
trained that understand the area very
well whereas if someone is only coming
and doing it for a week or two a year um
that might not be someone that becomes a
go-to for the judges to appoint because
they're just not doing it every day with
lots of training and lots of knowledge
in the area and I'm wondering if G's
are your your new attorneys uh those
that just passed the bar or if there's a
good uh array of of experience versus
someone who's uh someone who just
started that's a good question I'll look
into that I think many judges do appoint
someone that they've seen before and
have confidence in but there there are
always new people entering so that's a
good question what our balance is
okay uh any other questions
I I would just like to say I think they
definitely need to make sure that
they're trained well and um and I think
also too that they need to make sure um
because the big the biggest thing is um
as we know the work shortage is a big
problem out there and um I know within
the court system I heard them speaking
to uh I went to the conquered court and
they said you know it's hard to even get
people in to work and so I think we need
to make sure um that if we're doing this
is a very important um for the cases
that we need to make sure that somehow
these um people need to be um I guess um
paid appropriately because it is um a
very if especially if the um the judges
are going to want this and as well as
you know I think they need to make sure
that they compensate them well because
um just like everything um I said
somewhere another um I'm noticing
throughout we know it's a work shortage
throughout I'm talking to so many people
throughout the um the court system not
only court system but at the jail system
the police police departments everybody
is looking for um because uh to looking
for employees people are leaving left
and right and we need to somehow find
some kind of solution for this because
um I know myself as a nurse um we have a
lot of people um even within the um
Health Care System that's um also but we
need somehow to find um an answer to
some of this and um but like I said this
is so important especially for the court
system to move forward and everything
too thank
you thank you um I I also agree that I
that this is um incredibly important I
think the more we get into even Society
the complication of cases and what we're
looking at and um the psychology I would
like to see and it doesn't look like
there's any restriction on who can be a
a g it just happens to be I think more
lawyers or stuff but encouraging people
from other um pertinent um uh you know
of pertinent parts of the workforce that
might help with this too but I I think
the biggest thing is I I think the ones
that need this the most are probably the
ones that can't afford it so I do think
that there that's something we
definitely need to look at and we also
heard from the judge that that would be
like her one big like wish list that we
you know that they would have is to be
able to provide this to people um so I
do think that we have a lot of work and
as a um as legislators I think we have
a uh a strong responsibility to try to
make sure that we can get this in the
hands of the people that really need it
sure
so can you can you spell your last name
for me crean c r e e g
n from the Irish for
heart rather than I think uh there's a
German spelling but I'm Irish rather
than
German but I have I have cards I I'll
give you cards so you have okay
and uh do you have uh
Christina staff uh some you could send
whatever typically been sending it to
her so she can distribute it to you
right thank you so much and I know and I
know we next meet uh I think he's
looking at the first week in November uh
to get this committee uh the full
committee uh back up which we will be uh
reporting our our
uh findings so thank you thank you eron
great and if you have any other
questions you think of just let me know
and I'll I'll hunt down the right person
to answer them and fantastic get you
expertise more expert than my own thank
you thank you thank you so much for your
time okay any other uh any other area I
think we pretty much got it covered yeah
I think so very good perfect okay we'll
uh I'll bring your pen that's we talked
about call a closing of the I'll call a
closing of this uh
hearing this subcommittee hearing thank
you